this is the tale of Captain Jack Sparrow
great music should be celebrated so I do
[Music]
pirates of the caribbean dead men tell
no tales
so pirates of the caribbean dead men
tell no tales is the fifth Pirates of
the Caribbean movie the years have gone
by in the Pirates of the Caribbean
universe as well as our actual world in
dead men tell no tales Captain Jack
Sparrow's ultimately passes primers just
sad to see but it's worked into the
story but this ghost named Salazar who
we outsmarted many many many years ago
back when he was super yarn like CGI
Jack Sparrow fascia is coming after him
because Jack Sparrow got him killed and
cursed meanwhile this other dude is
looking for the Trident of Poseidon for
his own means and motivations it all
leads to Jack Sparrow on a very
convoluted Pirates of the Caribbean
movie I mean let's face it the first
Pirates of the Caribbean movie that was
one of my favorite movies that summer
was a lot of fun Jack Sparrow was the
man and in my opinion no Pirates of the
Caribbean movie has actually been as
good as the first one I just think we're
kind of over at this point what I liked
in this movie was Salazar they have a
good villain when he's on screen he's
great he's super intimidating he's
menacing that teaser trailer yeah kind
of floating face syndrome I was like
this is supposed to look like that or is
that just bad CGI it looks like they
have sharpened it up ultimately
everything about him is moving like he's
still underwater because that's where he
died and got cursed it's a really neat
visual to his character Javier Bardem is
a great actor he is I mean he's
exaggerated I'm like if you weren't
cursed you'd have busted a blood vessel
just squeaking that word out my favorite
part of the movie was the backstory that
it showed in the trailer with young Jack
Sparrow outsmart Salazar gets in dead
and cursed that was a sweet scene but
ultimately you see it in the trailer and
it does that transgression that movies
do worth like Oh backstory here's how
Jack Sparrow got all of his clothes I
don't give a where he got his
clothes and like I said it's a pretty
convoluted messy movie this movie has a
bunch of branches and side quests in it
you know we have to have Barbosa in it
here you go there's just weird witch
lady who she who knows there's other
lady who's an astronomer who people
think she's a witch but she's not a
witch but there's actually a witch
government dudes are hunting them
doesn't matter like there's this wedding
scene in the movie it's just like why is
this happening this is actually the
scene in the movie where I'm like you
need to just stop this joke pull it out
of the movie the movie will be no
different whatsoever you want people to
meet up they can meet up else
doesn't I don't know what's happening
and he's seen in the Pyrus movie that
makes me just roll my eyes it's a bad
sign
and / Pirates of the Caribbean Laura
that you have learned from the other
movies some of the backstory elements in
here it doesn't actually line up and
make sense and had you stressed that
Captain Jack Sparrow the character at
this point in his life is not the Jack
Sparrow we love for the reasons we loved
him he's not me anyway in the first
movie Captain Jack Sparrow was clever he
was witty yeah he looked kind of like a
weirdo drunk he carried himself like
that anyway but in the end when he
pulled something off and he's sailing
away someone could just stop and are and
be like that's gonna be the greatest
pirate I've ever seen it happened in the
first movie justifiably so like I see
where he had Elizabeth Turner this will
be the day you will always remembers the
day you almost caught Captain Jack
Sparrow tosses her takes the rope goes
up wraps the rope around something he's
flying around you're like what this guy
is straight up escaping Masterclass
style
this guy's not the idiot we thought he
was now and Jack Sparrow pulls something
off in this movie it's almost by mistake
he's a big idiot getting dragged by a
room and if he pulls it off it happens
by accident he's ultimately a buffoon
it's a bummer they concentrate so much
on the comedic slapstick of Captain Jack
Sparrow that they leave his wit behind
and in the end he was always if he
wasn't the smartest guy in the room he
was the most clever as in the end
pirates of the caribbean dead men tell
no tales is a Pirates of the Caribbean
sequel that came out a few years after
anyone really cares came out a few years
past it's Brian it tries it's best to
tie it in with the Pirates of the
Caribbean story and in some points it
does its job well enough but in its
execution it's messy it's sloppy I'm
kind of over the Captain Jack Sparrow
thing as they're making him however when
I watch pirates 1 he's still great means
there's something they hid in that movie
that they're not hitting anymore it has
some entertaining action sequences out
to sea it really does but also a lot of
these scenes when they're on the deck of
a ship you can tell is green-screen in
the first movie a lot of it was actually
outside hate to keep comparing it to the
first movie but I think it is applicable
to compare a pirates movie to a pirates
movie of the same franchise I can't deny
I was entertaining some of the action
sequences in particular is this
guillotine scene I always called a
guillotine but then other people call it
guillotine but the sake of possible
illiteracy I'm going to keep calling it
guillotine it was actually pretty
intentionally mmmm I will say pirates of
the caribbean dead men tell no tales
he's probably a better time with a nice
bottle of rum and i was supposed to be
sure drinks all around alright guys so
Pirates of the Caribbean
men tell no tales have you seen it what
did you think about it and what's the
order of the Pirates of the Caribbean
movies that you like and/or love
whatever there are whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]